SO BOTH OF THESE ARE FROM OUR. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE THIS IS OUR
FIRST HEARING OF. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO OF SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE OF TWO OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE NOT
ABLE TO. ATTEND TODAY- AND- VIA
AND THEN A COUPLE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE NEXT DOOR
IN OTHER COMMITTEES. VIA. WE'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE ROLL YET BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
ARE GONNA ACT AS A SUB COMMITTEE
. AND HERE AS MANY BILLS AS WE
CAN. AND THEN ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. ONCE WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WILL START VOTING. ON
BILLS- BOB I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND PRESENT THE FIRST. BILL I
HAVE A BILL. AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE THERE ARE FOLKS HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO IT AND
WILL FOLLOW OUR USUAL PROCEDURES
WITH THE- PHONE IN. TESTIMONY AS
WELL SINCE. WELCOME BACK MR
COOLEY HOW'D YOU DO YES NOT NEXT
DOOR. I THOUGHT I HEARD CHEERS
COMING UP FROM. BEHIND THE WALL. I CAN- SINCE YOUR BACK AND YOU
HAVE TO BILLS WANT WANT YOU GO
AHEAD PRESENT- WE'RE GONNA ACT
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. THERE TWELVE
BILLS ON THE CALENDAR TODAY
SEVEN OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT
I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT FOR
EACH OF THE TWELVE BILLS.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING. 877-692-8957 AND
ENTERING THE CODE. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. FOR BY
VISITING THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. MR COOLEY
WILL PROCEED NOW WITH AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AS OPEN ON THE BILL I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND HONOR TO SIT
UNDER THE GAZE OF IRELAND TO
HOLD OVER THERE I WORKED WITH
HER AND SHE SUCCESSFULLY IMPROVE
THE SENATE BY GETTING ELECTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY- OR TOLERATING IT
IS THAT HAPPENED ACTIONS. ANYWAY
I THINK WE'RE BETTER OFF. AREA.
GOOD MORNING MR CHARMERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR THIS
STREAMLINES THE CONFERENCE ROOMS
GUARANTY ASSOCIATION ABILITY
MAKE FUNDING READILY ACCESSIBLE
AND LESS COSTLY TO ACCESS SO
IT'S A SINGLE BILL AND SICK OF
COURSE IS THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR CONSUMERS IS RATE
MAKING TO MAKE SURE THAT RATES
ARE ADEQUATE FOR INSURANCE. BUT
IF THERE'S EVER THE EVENTUAL OF
AN INSURANCE COMPANY THAT
STUMBLES AND RUNS INTO
INSOLVENCY THAN CIGNA KICKS IN
SILVER SO THE ADVERSE EFFECTS OF
INSUFFICIENT REYES DOESN'T
FALLING CONSUMER THE SYSTEM
KICKS IN AND ALL CHARACTERS IN
THAT LINE. OOPS SO THIS IS A
SEEK A BILL SUPPORTING THIS ROLE
OF PROTECTING CONSUMERS THERE
ARE. SEGA'S CURRENT SUBJECT TO
TWO STATUES WHICH ALLOW C. COULD
ISSUE BONDS BONDS AS A SOURCE OF
REVENUE IN THE EVENT OF A
NEEDING FUNDS TO COVER. COVERED
CLAIMS ONE DEALS WITH NATURAL
DISASTER OF IMMENSE- AND THE
SECOND WAS TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION BONDS SOLD TO
LARGER AS WE CAN HAVE AN
INORDINATE YOUR CLAIMS THAT
CUTTING IT WITH THE ADVERSE
TIMING FOR THE INSURANCE SYSTEM.
ARM AND OF THE BOND TO PROVIDE
REVENUE THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
WHEN EXISTING FUNDS AND
ASSESSMENTS ARE NOT SERVICE TO
COVER CLAIMS. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FOUR REPEALS THE
PROVISIONS FOR THE SIG ISSUANCE
OF NATURAL DISASTER BONDS. WHICH
IS A SEPARATE PROVISION. AND
REVISES THE BOND PROVISIONS FOR
WORKERS COMP TO INCLUDE DENTAL
DISASTER AS WELL. SO IT'S
CONSOLIDATES THIS BOND AUTHORITY
INSEEGO UNDER ONE STEP TOWARD
MECHANISM. OF STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS FOR COMBINED THESE TWO
STATUTES WILL MAKE IT A SINGLE
BONDAGE WAS MORE EFFICIENT. ON
THERE'S ALSO A- SINCE EVERY
KERRIER IS SUPPOSED TO HELP
SUPPORT THE SYSTEM AND BEARS
SURCHARGES THAT GO ACROSS ALL
THOSE IDENTICAL PRODUCTS THERE
IS A POTENTIAL GAP IN THE CIGNA
STATUTE PERTAINING TO THE NEW
MEMBER SURCHARGE CURRENTLY THE
SURCHARGES BASED ON THE SICK IS
A SEPARATE FROM A PREVIOUS YEAR.
IF YOU WERE A NEW CARRIER ON THE
MARKET YOU DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
PREVIOUS YEAR SO THERE'S NOT A
CARE SURCHARGE MECHANISM. AND
RATHER LET A NEW CARRIER SALAS
PRODUCT BELOW THE SURCHARGE RATE
FOR A YEAR WHICH IS NOT. FAIR TO
EVERYBODY WHO HAS THIS
OBLIGATION BE A PARSI GO. ON
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE.
OF WHEN A NEW COMPANY BECOMES
LIGHTS A CALIFORNIA COMPANY
COLLECTS THE SURCHARGE YOU DOES
NOT RECEIVED ASSESSMENT. THE
SEARCH ARE DUE TO BE COLLECTED
AS I SEE TO AVOID OUT FOR
COMPETITION. THIS BILL ACTUALLY
REQUIRES YOU GET A OUT DROPPED A
PLAN OF OPERATION REQUIRES ALL
MEMBER INSURERS RECOUP DISKS. TO
CHARGE PAPER MATURE THROUGH A
SURCHARGE OF PREMIUMS CHARGED
FOR INSURANCE POLICIES IN THE
YEAR FOLLOWING THE PREMIUM
CHARGE. ANY SURCHARGES COLLECTED
DID BE REMITTED TO SEE GOOD USED. TO PAY FUTURE INSOLVENCIES.
FIVE SICK HAS IDENTIFIED ISSUES
WITH CYBERSECURITY POLICIES.
BECAUSE THESE POLICIES TAILORED
TO A VERY SPECIFIC TYPE OF
PROBLEM- THERE ARE CERTAIN
BENEFITS WHICH ARE NOT ALWAYS
CONSIDERED INSURANCE IS FOR TO
GET INTO A GRAY AREA SADE UNIQUE
TO CALIFORNIA ALL GUARANTEED SO
SHE'S FACED SIMILAR ISSUES. SO
SIGNAL IS TERRIFYING IN
CALIFORNIA'S DID REMOVE ANY
AMBIGUITIES AS TO COVERAGE. AND
SEE FOR A CYBER SECURITY PRODUCT
. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR
CLARIFIES OF CYBER SECURITY
POLICIES ARE COVERED CLAIMS AS
LONG AS HE GETS TOTAL
LIABILITIES NOW EXCEED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OR THE POLICY
LIMITS WHICHEVER IS LESS. OUR BY
DRESSING THESE GAPS IN CEDAR
STATUTE THIS WILL ALLOW YOU SO
SHOULD QUICK RESPOND WHEN CANCER
RENTS RESULT IN INSOLVENCIES.
AND CALIFORNIA SEEK RELEASE. A
SEEK RELIEF PARTLY AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FOUR SUPPORT BY SEEK AND
RECEIVE NO OPPOSITION AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO HAVE- JOHN NORWOOD
HERE'S BEGINS THE SUPPORT THE
BILL FOR SIKA. ROLE WITH. THEM
THE- GERMAN MEMBERS JOHN NOR
WOULD I BE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE GUARANTY ASSOCIATION
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS I
DON'T THINK I CAN ADD TOO MUCH
MORE. THAN THAT MR COOLEY IS
ALREADY DONE BUT I THINK IS
REALLY CRITICAL TO CLARIFY THAT
A CYBER INSURANCE IS A COVERED
CLAIM UNDER US AGAIN THAT THIS
BILL DOES THAT AND SECONDLY IT
MADE NOTHING BUT SENSE TO TAKE
THE TO STATUTES AUTHORIZING. US
TO GET ISSUE BONDS IN THE- EVENT
OF A- CASH FLOW CRISIS AND PUT
IT INTO THE ONE- AUTHORITY
THAT'S BEEN USED AND HAS PROVEN
TO BE VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFICIENT SO- FOR THOSE REASONS
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND- DRIVE
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NOR WOULD- WE
WILL IN. ANY SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL AT THIS
POINT. ARE THERE ANY PERSONS
HERE WHO WE WISH TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. LET'S GO THEN
TO OUR PHONE LINES WHICH IS OUR
PRACTICE- MR OPERATOR ARE YOU
WITH US. YES A RESEARCHER WE ARE
WAITING FOR YOU. BEAUTIFUL WOULD
YOU WERE. IS ANYONE IN THE LINE
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL- IS THE GENTLEMAN TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE'S
KEYPAD. THE AFFORDABLE QUITE
MATURE LINE NUMBERS WITH THE
LINE NUMBERS CALLED STATE YOUR
NAME THE LOCATION IN YOUR
POSITION. ONE MOMENT DENTURE.
ONCE AGAIN TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. MR SURELY
HAVE NO RESPONDENTS GIVING UP
GOOD THANK YOU AND WE'LL GET
BACK TO YOU HERE IN JUST A
MINUTE OR SO. FOR THE OPPOSED
TESTIMONY AS OR ANYONE HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. WHO DARES TO OPPOSE
THE BILL- NO IT'S OF GREAT BILL
WITH A GREAT AUTHOR AND- WELL
WE'LL FIND OUT SO. THIS IS A
GOOD ONE. AND MR OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL. WHEN ONCE AGAIN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN MR SURE WE HAVE NO
RESPONDENTS THINK. THANK YOU SIR
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE WON'T BE
VOTING HAVE YET ON THIS BILL BUT
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME. MR VOEPEL. NOT A
QUESTION JUST A- COMMENT ON THE
BILL WONDERFUL BILL AND I REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT- WHEN
COMPANIES GO BROKE USUALLY
BETWEEN CIGNA AND INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THEY FIND A
CONSORTIUM OR OTHER COMPANIES
THAT WILL BY THE BROKE COMPANIES
SO THIS IS SIMPLY LIKE THE THIRD
BACKSTOP IN THE SYSTEM. GREAT
BILL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR
COMING THANK YOU MR VOEPEL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MYLEX AKON IF NOT WE WILL- WILL
BE VOTING ON THAT AT THE- WHEN
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS ITSELF
THANK YOU FOR THAT BILL MR
COOLEY THANK YOU MISTER NORWOOD.
AND NOW WE'RE HEARING AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT ALSO BY MR
COOLEY. VERY GOOD. YOU SCOTT.
WERE GO AHEAD CAN OUR COLLEAGUES
AND PLEASED TO BE HERE PRESENT
THIS BILL AND- THIS IS ABOUT THE
SHORTEST INSURANCE BILL YOU WILL
ENCOUNTER- LOOKS LIKE ABOUT-
SEVEN EIGHT LINES OF TEXT THE
UPSHOT IS THERE ARE THREE VERY
IMPORTANT CLASSIFICATIONS OF
REGULAR REGULATED ENTITIES UNDER
INSURANCE. THEY ARE PRODUCERS OF
SURPLUS LINES BROKERS AND LIFE
AND DISABILITY INSURANCE
ANALYSTS HERE BROAD CLASSES OF
LICENSEES SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE
VERY OFTEN AND- THIS BILL
ACTUALLY RELATES TO THE FACT
THAT THROUGH TIME INSURANCE SORT
OF JUST ITSELF TO WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE WORLD YEAH. BECAUSE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FINALLY WROTE THE
RULES FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS BY
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO VOTERS
APPROVED MORE BROADLY IN THE
STATE. AND A LOT IS IN SUIT FROM
THAT AND THE ISSUE OF THIS BILL
IS SIMPLY. IF A PRODUCER SURPLUS
LINES BROKER LIFE AND DISABILITY
ANALYST IS DOING SOMETHING
INVOLVING WRITING MARIJUANA DO
THEY VIOLATE THEIR LICENSING LAW
IN THIS BILL SAYS NO SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE NATURAL ON THE BILL
DIDN'T TAKE VERY. TO ME LINES
WHICH HAVES OF THOSE THREE CLASS
OF LICENSEES ARE NOT- DO NOT
COMMIT A CRIME UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW SOLELY PROVIDING INSURANCE
RELATED SERVICES TO PERSONS
LICENSE GAUGING COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS ACTIVITY. SO- AS I SAY
VOTERS APPROVED USYK CANVAS FOR
MEDICAL PURPOSES IN NINETY SIX
BEGIN TO PRODUCE OF ADULT
CANNABIS USE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
CALPERS WERE TO STAND UP AND
WILL REGULATE CANNABIS MARKET
PLACE. AN AREA WHERE COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY HAS LAGGED HOWEVER HAS
BEEN INSURANCE COVERAGE.
ALTHOUGH CANVASES FEDERALLY
ILLEGAL LONGSTANDING GUIDELINES
FROM THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT TO
ALLOW FOR INSTITUTIONS TO WORK
OR CAMPUS BUSINESSES PROVIDED
THEY FOLLOW CERTAIN. EXTRA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THERE'S
ALSO FEDERAL CASE LAW INDICATES
DONORS GREEN EARTH WELLNESS
CENTER VERSES ATTAINS PROVENCHER
AND COMPANY. THAT'S A TWENTY
SIXTEEN CASE THAT ESTABLISHED
THAT FEDERAL CLASSIFICATION
CANVAS IS NOT RELEVANT IN AN
INSURANCE PROVIDERS DETERMINES
TO WRITE AN INSURANCE POLICY.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE FROM
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THE MCCARRAN
FERGUSON ACT A FEDERAL LAW WHICH
STATES HAS STATES REGULATE THEIR
OWN INSURANCE MARKETPLACES NOT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO IS
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET HAS GROWN
FOR CANNABIS SO HAS THE NEED FOR
INSURANCE FOR CULTIVATORSTESTING LABS- AND RETAIL
CURRENTLY ONLY EIGHT IT BEEN
INSURERS PROVIDE INSURANCE FOR
CANVASSING CALIFORNIA- AND WHILE
THERE ARE MANY SURPLUS LINE
INSURERS ARE PROVIDING SURE SIR
POLICIES ONLY COVER THE RETAIL
MARKET. AUTOMATION TESTING
COVERAGE WHICH REQUIRES A
CORPORATION ADMITTED INSURERS
PROVIDE PRODUCT IS NOT COVERED.
AS A RESULT THERE IS A SHORTAGE
IN PROVIDERS AND COVERAGE IN THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS MARKET
PLACE. AND AS WITH ANY BUSINESS
IT'S IMPORTANT A COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ALL PRESENT
A CALIFORNIA LAW HAVE ACCESS TO
BROAD INSURANCE PRODUCTS TO
SUPPORT THEIR SURVIVAL AS A
BUSINESS LINE. SO THIS BILL
TERRIFIED TO RUN INSURANCE FOR
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE A CRIME SINCE CANVAS
IS PART OF A LEGAL REGULATED
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA- IT DOES
NOT MANDATE THE CREATION OF A
PRODUCT. AND ALWAYS USED TO
CLARIFY EXISTING PRAXIS STATUE
TO ENCOURAGE GREATER
PARTICIPATION MARKETPLACE AS I
SAID IT DOESN'T BY. CLARIFYING
THE LICENSING STATUTES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NOT RUN
AFOUL OF THE LAW. OF THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA FARM
CHURCH IT HAS RECEIVED OFF.
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE MICHAEL
MARTINEZ WILL JOIN US- TO OFFER
TEST WHEN SUPPORT THE BILL FOR
COMMISSIONER LARA. THANK YOU MR
COOLEY WE HAVE A QUORUM OF
PRESENCE SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD. AND TAKE THE ROLL CALL
NOW TO ESTABLISH THE QUORUM.
DALY HERE DALY HERE SANTIAGO.
BERMAN BIGELOW CALDERON CALDERON
HERE CERVANTES TORONTO'S HERE
CHEN CHEN HERE COOLEY HERE
COOLEY HERE COOPER GIPSON.
GRAYSON GRAYSON HERE RODRIGUEZ
VOEPEL YOU VOEPEL HERE WHAT
WOULD HERE. AND WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AND-
THERE'S A MOTION ON MR COOLEY'S
BILL. WHICH IS AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND- NOW WILL GO TO. WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
TO ANYONE PRESENT WHO'D LIKE TO
COMMENT. IF NOT WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MR OPERATOR PLEASE.
FOR WITNESSES- FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT- WELL WOULD HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH THIS ONLINE I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE OVER
HERE FOR A FORTUNE. IT'S UP
FORTY ONE OF THE PUBLIC IT'S
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT SIR AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT YEAH.
CORRECT WHAT IS A LINES ARE OPEN
IF YOU'RE EVER TESTIFYING IN
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY. GOOD MORNING
SURE DALY. GOOD MORNING NUMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL HI YES
HI GOOD MORNING MICHAEL MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
LEGISLATIVE SECTOR. VIRTUALLY
HERE ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE GIVEN THE FIRST AND
SECOND I'LL BE INCREDIBLY BRIEF
JUST TO SAY THAT COMMISSIONER
LARA IS SPONSORING AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AND HE'S PROUD
TO BECAUSE HE BELIEVES THAT. WE
MUST PROVIDE COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WITH MULTIPLE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE ADMITTED
INSURANCE COVERAGE OPTIONS. TO
COVER ALL ASPECTS OF THE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES FROM SEED TO
SALE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
BUSINESSES CAN CONTINUE TO FORCE
IN CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HER AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MARTINEZ. NEXT. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE. MR
OPERATOR. GIVE JOIN OTHER
WITNESS TO TESTIFY ON THIS BILL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. APPROVAL OF NOBODY ELSE
ASIDE JOIN AS A WITNESS FOR
TESTIMONY COULD LIKE TO GO TO
THE PUBLIC ON PHONE LINES WE GO
THAT DIRECTION. AND AGAIN-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESPONDENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU LET'S GO TO ANY OPPOSED
TESTIMONY ANYONE HERE IN THE- IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'S OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THERE IS NOT
APPEAR TO BE ANYONE LET'S GO TO
THE- PHONE IN TESTIMONY MR
OPERATOR AGAIN PLEASE. OF THOSE
WITH A JOINT AS WITH THE SINCE
IF YOU'RE HERE FOR THIS BILL I
WAS OPPOSITION YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MICHIGAN. OKAY LOOKS LIKE NONE
OF THE WITNESSES WHO HAVE JOINED
BY PHONE OR HERE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILLS WILL GO TO THE
PUBLIC. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
VOICE OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MISTER ARNOLD RESPONDED SECU
THANK YOU SIR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SO ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF MR COOLEY ON THIS
BILL. OR MAKE COMMENTS. IT'S A
COOLEY BILL SO WE KNOW IT'S
SOLID. ALL RIGHT THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING- SUPPORT- LET'S GO
AHEAD AND VOTE THEN TIFFANY IS A
MOTION AND SECOND. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT COOLEY MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS DALY HI DALY AYE
SANTIAGO BERMAN. BIGELOW BIGELOW
NOT VOTING CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES AYE TORONTO'S AYE CHAN
. CHEN I COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
COOPER GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOT
VOTING WHAT WOULD I. RIGHT
THAT'S ONE VOTE SHORT BUT-
THEY'LL BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ADD
ON- LET'S DO LET'S VOTE ON MR
COOLEY'S PREVIOUS BILL. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR SINCE MR
COLLISION. DRIVER'S SEAT THERE.
MS MOTION AND SECOND ON AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR THIS ALSO
ENJOYS A SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
THIS IS A DO PASS AND- WILL DO
ROLL CALL VOTE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR
COOLEY. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY HI DALY I
SANTIAGO. BERMAN BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE CHAN AYE
CHAN AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE RODRIGUEZ. VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD WOULD I. GOOD THAT HAS
NINE I VOTE SO THAT BILL IS ON
TO APPROPRIATIONS LET'S VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR NOW THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IN THERE ARE
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I
NEED TO READ THESE INTO THE
RECORD ITEM ONE AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FOUR. ITEM TO AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY EIGHT ITEM THREE AB
EIGHTEEN OH FIVE ITEM SIX AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE ITEM EIGHT A.
B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE. I AM NOT
. I AM NINE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. AN ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE THOSE SEVEN BILLS
ARE ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THOSE BEFORE
WE VOTE- LET'S GO AHEAD ROLL
CALL VOTE TIFFANY. DALY AYE DALY
AYE SANTIAGO BERMAN BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CALDERON CALDERON
AYE CERVANTES THROUGHOUT HIS AYE
CHAN CHAN I COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER GIPSON GRAYSON. GRAYSON
AYE RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD I WOULD I. GOOD THANK YOU
ALL WE HAVE THREE BILLS
REMAINING- MISTER RIVAS AND I'M
SORRY MS RIVAS AND MR SANTIAGO
ARE NOT. HERE YET AND- THOSE ARE
TWO OF THE REMAINING BILLS AND
THEN I HAVE THE THIRD I'M ASKED
MR VOEPEL- TO. TAKEOVER IS CHAIR
WOULD YOU CAST THEM DOWN AND I'M
GONNA PRESENT A BILL. HERE FROM
MY CHAIR. AND- GET TO THE. VERY
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY A.
B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE SIR THANK
YOU. THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS
THE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
CURRENT COVERT RELATED WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS STANDS
FOR TWO MORE YEARS UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE
TWO PRESUMPTIONS IN THIS BILL
RECUPERATED BY S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH I JOIN AUTHORED- WITH THE
SENATOR. JERRY HILL. ACTUALLY I
WAS PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. THE TWO
PRESUMPTIONS PROVIDE FOR
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT A
PEACE OFFICER FIREFIGHTER
SPECIFIED FRONTLINE EMPLOYEES IN
CERTAIN HEALTH CARE EMPLOYEES
WHO CONTRACT COVERT NINETEEN
WERE INFECTED WITH THE VIRUS AT
THE WORK PLACE AND THE SECOND
ESTABLISHES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR EMPLOYEES WHO
CONTRACT OVER NINETEEN FROM ANY
EMPLOYER THAT EXPERIENCES AN
OUTBREAK. OF KOBE NINETEEN CASES
AT A PARTICULAR WORK LOCATION.
EXTENDING THESE PRESUMPTIONS
WILL ALLOW WORKERS IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN TO MORE EASILY
ACCESS THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM AND RECEIVE THE CARE AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED WITHOUT DELAY.
ALSO IT WILL ENCOURAGE WORKERS
WHO CONTRACT THE VIRUS AT THE
WORK PLACE TO REMAIN HOME AND
RECEIVE CARE INSTEAD OF FURTHER
SPREADING THE ILLNESS AS A
SPREAD OF CLOVER NINETEEN
HOPEFULLY DIMINISHES. CLAIMS
WILL NATURALLY DECREASE AND
PRESUMPTIONS WILL BE USED LESS
FREQUENTLY BUT STILL REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE IN NEED.
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS MAY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU MEGAN GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MAKE
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. BUT WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND ALSO THE
ORIGINAL BILL SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE. BUT WE ARE OBVIOUSLY IN A
IN A BETTER CONDITION IN TERMS
OF KOPET NINETEEN RIGHT NOW BUT
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO STAY
AHEAD. OF THE VARIANTS THAT-
WE'VE SEEN AND THE ONES THAT
COULD BE COMING- SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE THINK EXTENDING THIS
PRESUMPTION. IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT- FRONTLINE WORKERS
INCLUDING FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM AND- TIMELY
ACCESS TO MEDICAL TREATMENT IF
THEY ARE DIAGNOSED WITH THIS
WORK RELATED- I ILLNESS AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MR VOEPEL A THIS CAN BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR WILL WE CAN GO
STRAIGHT TO THE- PHONE IN
TESTIMONY I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. GOING TO THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT. MR ROBERT
ALLEN IS A WITNESS TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAKE ON YOUR PHONE
BEGIN. AS SOON WE HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. IS THERE
ANY WE DO HAVE MORE WITNESSES
DIALED IN BUT APPARENTLY NOT FOR
THE BILL WILL GO HEAD TO THE
PUBLIC AND THAT'S ONE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE TO VOICE IN SUPPORT. AND
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE. TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBERS CARS PLAYING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANKS WE GO TO LINE TWENTY LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS ERIC HARRIS GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT
OF- THE BILL. MR YOU HAVE ONE
MORE QUEUING UP IT'LL BE JUST
ONE MOMENT IT'S. SOME OF THE
BILL I THINK IT'S GOING TO LINE
NUMBER FOURTEEN ONE FOURTEEN
ALONSO COMPLAINTS. JOE WELL
MCCORD COMPARING READING
ASSISTANCE ON BEHALF OF CAL FIRE
LOCAL TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN AND THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL IN PORT THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT MISTER
CHEROKEE WAS QUICKER. VERY WELL
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. THIS DROP
RAIDER ANYONE ON THE PHONE FOR
OPPOSITION. TO VOICE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND GENERAL
CONSTRUCTION. RIGHT. I HAVE A I
BELIEVE IN THE MAIN OPPONENT ON
THE SECOND. MY THREE SPEAK.
MISTER. MISTER JASON MITCHELL
TALKING YES OKAY- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MY NAME IS
JASON SHELTER AND I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND PRISON PUBLIC
RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS IN
MANAGEMENT- I'VE ALSO BEEN OUT
TO DELIVER MY COMMENT ON BEHALF
OF SEVERAL OF OUR COALITION
PARTNERS SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR- AND HIS STAFF FOR
THE TIME THAT THEY AND TALKING
TO US ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND OUR
CONCERNS. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL- OUR COALITION OPPOSE THE
PASSAGE OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
AND TWENTY TWENTY BUT WE WORKED
IN GOOD FAITH WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO PASS THE TIME
LIMITED EMERGENCY MEASURE THAT
WENT THE EXTRA MILE TO PROTECT
WORKERS IN THE MIDST OF AN
UNFOLDING PANDEMIC TO BE CLEAR
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS HAVE
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE
RESPONSIBLY FIELDED OVER A
QUARTER MILLION WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS FOR COVERED
NINETEEN. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SAFELY ALLOW
THIS POLICY TO SUNSET HAS
PLANNED ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THIS IS FOR SEVERAL
REASONS VERY QUICKLY- FIRST
THERE ARE MULTIPLE VACCINES
AVAILABLE TO EMPLOYEES WHO WISH
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM THE
MOST SEVERE CONSEQUENCES OF
COVERT NINETEEN SECONDS THE
CALLOW J. EGS PROVIDES EXTENSIVE
PROTECTION TO EMPLOYEES AND
MAKES THE WORKPLACE AMONG THE
SAFER ENVIRONMENTS OUT THERE-
AND THIRD THE PRESUMPTION IS
DONE ITS JOB IT PROVIDED BROAD
AND HINDERED ACCESS TO THE
WORKERSCOMPENSATION SYSTEM IN
THE MIDST OF A PANDA UNFOLDING
PANDEMIC. BUT THE CONDITIONS
HAVE CHANGED SUBSTANTIALLY SO
DESPITE OUR BELIEF THAT THE
PRESUMPTION COULD SAFELY SUNSET-
WE UNDERSTAND WHY LEGISLATORS
MIGHT NOT BE READY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE-
AND THE CODE NINETEEN ROLLER
COASTERS TAUGHT US ALL TO BE
CAUTIOUS WE UNDERSTAND THAT FOR
THAT REASON WE WOULD BE WILLING
TO REMOVE OPPOSITION TO THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS PRESUMPTION
UNDER TWO CIRCUMSTANCES- ONE- ON
THE CONDITION THAT NO DETAILS OF
THE UNDERLYING POLICY CHANGE SO
THAT THE POLICY. THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED IN 2020% IT'S- INTO
IN THE IS THE AND- PIECE- BUT
YOU KNOW RELATIVE TO WHAT'S IN
THE CURRENT- IF THE BILL WERE
AMENDED TO EXT. THE SUNSET FOR
ONE YEAR INSTEAD OF TWO- IF IT'S
NEEDED FOR TO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALWAYS DECIDE TO COME BACK
AND DO THAT AGAIN NEXT YEAR- BUT
WE DON'T SEE ANY REASON TO
EXTEND IT FOR TWO YEARS. AT THIS
POINT- AND WITHOUT THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
VERY WELL THANK YOU. ANY ONE
ELSE. ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. VERY WELL AND- THERE WAS TWO
SUGGESTIONS. THERE WAS TWO
SUGGESTIONS FOR AN AMENDMENT-
DOES THE AUTHOR WANT TO DO ANY
AMENDMENTS. OF READ RESPECTFULLY
ALL DECLINE NOW. THOSE
SUGGESTIONS AT THIS TIME ROGER
THAT THEY'RE WELL TAKEN BONTA.
WE'VE HAD A LONG JOURNEY HERE WE
WANT TO STAY ON THE ON THE PATH
. THEN THERE'S NO MORE
OPPOSITION IN ROOM OR ON THE
PHONE CORRECT. COMMITTEE
COMMENTS NEWSLETTER DEFAULT DID
YOU OBJECT PUBLIC COMMENT
PROPOSITION. YEAH YES THEY
RECOMMENDED OF THE PUBLIC TO
VOTERS IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO. SECRETLY OPPOSITION ON THE
PUBLIC SIDE OPPOSED VOICE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
FOR ALLOWING THAT THERE ARE NO
RESPONDENTS IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. A WELL. COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. C. NONE
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. MR COOLEY
MADE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND.
TWENTY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE AND- THANK MR VOEPEL
FOR CAN FOR A GOOD FOR BRINGING
ME TO THE ONE YARD LINE HERE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE DALY OUR
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IDENTIFY DALY I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO BERMAN BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW CALDERON CALDERON
AYE CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE CHAN
CHEN NOT VOTING COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER GIPSON GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WOULD WOOD I.
GOOD THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT
MISTER GRAYSON WILL MISS YOU
UNTIL YOUR RETURN. WILL HOLD A
HEARING OPEN INTO YOUR RETURNS
YOU CAN OUT ON MR VOEPEL THANK
YOU FOR SHARING- THAT BILL SO MR
SANTIAGO HAS ARRIVED. WHICH IS
BEAUTIFUL- MR SANTIAGO HAS A
BILL TO PRESENT AND HE'S FILLING
IN. FOR ONE OF OUR MISSING
MEMBERS I THINK FOR MR RODRIGUEZ
. WELCOME MR SANTIAGO. I THINK
THIS RETURN MEMBERS- AND BY THE
WAY THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT GO AHEAD SIR- SECOND
. IF THE IF THE COMMITTEE WISHES
MISTER CHAIR HUBBY BRIEF PLEASE
- AB TWENTY FORTY WOULD EXTEND
THE PAIR TO STUDY FROM
PREVIOUSLY MANDATED REPORT THE
MEDICAL TREATMENT OF INJURED
WORKERS WITH THE FORTY FIRST
THIRTY DAYS. OF FOLLOWING A
WORKERS COMP CLAIM- BASICALLY WE
SEEK TO DO IS EXTEND THE STUDY
BY TWO YEARS TO ENSURE THAT WE
COLLECT- THE PROPER DATA TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THE CASE OR NOT-
THAT WORKERS RECEIVING- THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE WITHIN THE FIRST THIRTY
DAYS OF INJURY- AND WITH US WE
HAVE A- ONE WITNESS MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY OKAY WITH YOU YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH STEIGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED THIS
BILLS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
DECIDES TO YEARS OF DATA TO THIS
STUDY. IT REALLY DOES GET TO
WHAT WE SEE AS A BROADER ISSUE
IN THE WORKERS COMP SYSTEM OF A
REAL LACK OF RELIABLE AND
COMPREHENSIVE DATA. CAN TELL YOU
HOW MANY TIMES A QUESTION COMES
UP ABOUT WORKERS COMP AND WE THE
ANSWER IS NOT KNOWN BECAUSE WE
JUST DON'T HAVE DATA ON IT THIS
IS ONE STEP TOWARD SOLVING THAT
PROBLEM TOWARDS WHAT WAS A
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND COULD GIVE US
A LOT OF IMPORTANT INFORMATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
WORKING. WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE- WE'VE HAD A FEW BILLS IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. WHERE WE
DESPERATELY NEEDED SOME CONTEXT
AND SOME DATA AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
IT SO THIS IS A- VERY WORTHY
PURSUIT HERE- WE'RE TAKING- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS POINT
. IF NOT WE'LL TAKE TESTIMONY GO
AHEAD THE THIS IS ON THIS IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST MEGHAN
SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE TO BE A CO
SPONSORED YOUR SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU MISS SUBER'S ANY OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR THE BILL. IF NOT LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND I HAVE TO
REMIND MYSELF AND EVERYONE ELSE
IT'S A TWO STEP PROCESS FIRST
THEIR SO CALLED WITNESSES WHO
PHONE IN AND THEN THERE IS THE
GENERAL PUBLIC- PHONES AND SO. I
APOLOGIZE FOR ANY CONFUSION
PREVIOUSLY. SO MR OPERATOR GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU STRUCTURE
WELL FOR THE PUBLIC TO VOICE
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO RESPONDENTS TO QUEUE.
UP HELLO I'M I'M IN THE QUEUE
SORRY- MY NAME IS SEAN MCNALLY-
BUT THE COMMISSION ON HEALTH
SIXTEEN WORKERS COMP THE PLAYER
REPRESENTATIVE. AND I AM CALLING
IN IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELLING
THING. ALL THE INFORMATION WE
CAN GET WILL HELP US. MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TRYING TO MAKE THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
BETTER FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MCNALLY. MISTER OPERATOR ANYONE
ELSE AND IN LINE. THE
RESEARCHERS NOBODY FROM THE
PUBLIC CONCERN IN THE QUEUE IS
POINT. YOU DO HAVE WITH THE
SERVER THE VIOLIN LINES ARE OPEN
FOR WHATEVER IT'S THEIR TURN TO
SPEAK BUT AS FAR AS THE PUBLIC
IS CONCERNED THERE ARE THE SOME
ONLY AND I'M PROBABLY HAS QUEUED
UP TO OPEN ONE. WITH SUPPORT.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
LINE MISTER OPERATOR. RICHARD
NOBODY IF YOU EVERY TIME I SAY
MISTER OPERATOR I THINK OF THE
WHOLE JIM CROCE SONG POP BERATER
WHATEVER THAT SONG WAS. YOU'RE
TOO YOUNG BUT ONLY AT LEAST-
WOULD YOU REMEMBER THE OLD NORTH. BUT FOR ME TO MONEY. WELCOME
TO MY HEAD ALL DAY BUT- HE SORRY
TO DO THAT YOU. BROWN'S IT'S NOT
BAD SONG. IN A NOTE ABOUT SOME-
SO ANYONE ELSE IN LINE. MR
OPERATOR. IF YOU HAVE JOINED AS
A WITNESS TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND IF IT'S
FOR THIS BILL YOU MAY PROCEED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LITTERING
LISTEN ONLY MODE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO TO QUEUE UP TO SPEAK.
ALL RIGHT- W. Q. ABOUT RESPONSE
FREQUENTIST THANK YOU SIR AND
LET I THINK I'VE OVERLOOKED
GIVING ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AGAINST
THE BILL. ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM. WANTS TO GIVE MR SANTIAGO
HARD TIME NOPE NO ONE OKAY. SO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THIS BILL. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND WE DO I
THINK I THINK. WHAT THE- SECOND
. WOW THE ECHO OF THAT SONG IN
MY HEAD I DIDN'T HEAR THAT I
DIDN'T HEAR YOU DO YOU WANT TO
SING YOUR MOTION MAY BE A LITTLE
BIT. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND ON THIS BILL. AND THIS IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT. ALL
CALL VOTE PLEASE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT SANTIAGO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DALY I NEGLECTED TO GIVE MR
SANTIAGO AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
THAT WITH OKAY BUT THE RISK OF
BEING RIDICULED WHEN YOU THOUGHT
MR OPERATOR I THOUGHT MR
TELEPHONE MAN. THAT'S GOOD I
RESPECTFULLY OFTEN OVERLOOKED
THAT'S GOOD. DALY HI DALY AYE
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE BERMAN
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE CALDERON
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE CHAN AYE
CHAN AYE COOLEY COOPER GIPSON
GRAYSON. RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL WOOD
WHAT I CALDERON ACT WALDRON I.
SEVEN FIVE VOTES AND- AFTER THE
ADD ONS HERE'S MR VOEPEL WAS
BACK IN MISTER COOPER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WERE ON A MR
VOEPEL MR COOPER WERE ON- AB%
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT BY MR
SANTIAGO WHICH ELECTED WE'RE
JUST VOTING NOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOTE. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
COOPER. COOPER I VOEPEL L. I.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS TEN AYE
VOTES I BELIEVE. GOOD SO WE HAVE
ONE REMAINING BILL BY
THREE OF US. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. WE- COMMISSIONS
FROM. YEAH LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ADD ON NOW- WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR MISS RIVAS. GO AHEAD TIFFANY
CONSENT CALENDAR. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I COOPER COOPER I
GIPSON RODRIGUEZ. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT COOLEY. SANTIAGO UNTIL I
BERMAN. COOPER COOPER I GIPSON
RODRIGUEZ. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BERMAN
COOPER COOPER I GIPSON. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE DALY BERMAN. COOPER
COOPER AYE GIPSON. FILE OVER
GOOD. OKAY WE'RE GOOD WE'VE
GIVEN EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD ON BEAUTIFUL MISTER WOULD-
JUST GENEROUSLY HAS OFFERED TO
PRESENT MS RIVAS IS BILL FOR HER
. AND SHE MAY ARRIVE SHE MAY
ARRIVE IN MID PRESENTATION BUT-
THAT'S OKAY GO AHEAD SIR DOESN'T
KNOW I'M DOING THIS HE DOESN'T
KNOW HE MAY BE RUNNING WEEK HERE
AT THIS POINT. WE DIDN'T ASK WE
DIDN'T ASK HER FOR PERMISSION
THAT'S NOT HOW WE OPERATE. WHAT
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF MISS A
MISS RIVAS THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE- THE AGENTS THE
AGENCY- THROUGH THAT SEE THE
INTEGRATED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY PROGRAM. TO
STUDY. IS MINISTER ATTY WAIT A
SECOND. I DON'T KNOW THIS BILL
VERY WELL SO IS THAT A SURPRISE
ANYBODY NOT NOW YOU TELL US.
YEAH I DON'T. WE'RE GOING TO SET
A STANDARD FOR HEAT IN THIS BILL
MR COOLEY SO WE'LL ALL BE ABLE
DECIDE WHETHER WE CAN STAND IT
OR NOT I THINK AT THIS POINT I
THINK IS A REALLY GOOD BILL AND
I KNOW THERE'S A CHANCE ON IT
COMES TO MY JUST KIDDING JUST
KIDDING SORRY THERE ARE ALWAYS A
YEAH WE HAVE A CAR WASH BLUES
HERE IN A MINUTE PLEASE. NO I
IT'S A- IT'S A GOOD BILL- THE
IDEA TO PROCRIT TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE EXTREME HEATING RANKED
THE RANKING SYSTEM. AND YEAH.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND- MS
RIVAS IS ON HER WAY FROM HER SHE
IS NOW A BUDGET HEARING YEAH
SHE'S SPRINTING YEAH. YOU MOVE.
ARE THE PERSON. GOOD YEAH THANK
YOU OR WHATEVER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D LOVE IT IF THEY WERE
REALLY HARD QUESTIONS FOR MR
WOOD RIGHT NOW ON THE BILL HERE
. GO AHEAD MR SANTIAGO MUCH
WE'RE GOOD WITH A CAPITAL.
THAT'S WHEN THERE'S EXTREME HEAT. YEAH BUT IF YOU HAVEN'T. I'D
LET DAD YOU. I THINK. WE'RE TO
LOOK THROUGH AND MISTER IN FOR
SOME WHEN SHE YEAH YEAH. IT'S
STILL THE BILL STILL ON THE
RAILS THOUGH IT'S NOT HASN'T
BEEN OFF THE RAILS HE QUITE YET
JIM CROCE SONG FOR THAT ONE-
YEAH. YEAH. LET'S SIR INVITE ANY
SUPPORTERS TO SPEAK ANY
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM OKAY IF NOT
WE'LL GO TO MR OPERATOR AND THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES OR FOR
ANY OTHER PUBLIC. SUPPORT
MISTRUST RAIDER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'VE DIALED IN
AS A WITNESS TO GIVE TESTIMONY
ON AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MIGHT ON
THE TEN BEGIN. A GOOD MORNING-
SHOULD CONSIDER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BOB PLEASE NOTE
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME- HI MY NAME
IS LOUIS BLOOMBERG AND I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ADRIENNE
ARSHT ROCKEFELLER FOUNDATION
RESILIENCE CENTER. AT THE
ATLANTIC COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT. OUR
STRUCTURE IS WE CALL IT IS
WORKING TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE DEADLY AND GROWING
THREAT OF EXTREME HEAT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES AND GLOBALLY.
I ALSO SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THE
CLIMATE INSURANCE WORKING GROUP
CONVENED BY CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. NOW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- SPECIAL YOU
MISTER DALY YOU REMEMBER MAY
REMEMBER FOUR YEARS AGO I
APPEARED. BEFORE YOU- IN THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE I AT THAT
POINT I WAS THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE CLIMATE
CHANGE PROBLEM WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. CAN YOU PASSED SB
THIRTY WELL I'M BACK HERE TODAY
WITH FOLLOW UP TO THAT BILL TO
LET YOU KNOW THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER HAS CONVENED A
COMMITTEE THAT THAT BILL
REQUIRED AND IS MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO YOU TODAY.
AND THESE TWO ITEMS I'M GOING TO
SPEAK ABOUT IT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT ARE THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATIONS FIRST OUTPUT IF
YOU WELCOME THAT THE WORK THAT
YOU DID ON SB THIRTY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SO S. AS MENTIONED
THIS BILL DEALS WITH EXTREME
HEAT EXTREME HEAT IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND A CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. RESILIENCE CHALLENGE
IN IMPACTS ALL OF OUR LIVES IN
MANY WAYS THAT OUR HELP OF
MIDDLE JUDY. REDUCES WORKER
SAFETY AND PRODUCTIVITY
INCREASES CHILDREN LEARNING AND
MUCH MUCH MORE HE KILLS MORE
PEOPLE THAN ANY OTHER CLIMATE
DRIVEN WEATHER EVENT YET IT IS
CONSIDERED THE SILENT KILLER
BECAUSE PEOPLE AND OFFICIALS. DO
NOT UNDERSTAND THE SEVERE HUMAN
AND ECONOMIC DEVASTATION IT
CAUSES. WE DON'T KNOW HOW
SERIOUS THE PROBLEM IS AND HOW
MUCH OF CLASSES TODAY WE CANNOT
RESPOND EFFECTIVELY SIR WILL YOU
HAVE IT. TOO MANY. SIR DO HAVE A
TWO MINUTE- TIME PERIOD FOR YOUR
TEST SUPPLY. PLEASE READ IT UP
OKAY. OKAY LET ME JUST TELL YOU
THAT WE LEARNED IN THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IS WORKING GROUP
THAT YOU CANNOT BUY THE
INSURANCE POLICY FOR HEAT YOU
CAN BUY ONE FOR FIRE AND FLOOD.
SO THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE A COST
ANALYSIS OF HEAT WAVES TO
CALIFORNIA- AND WILL IDENTIFY
WHO BEARS THE COST OGBENI WILL
BE ESSENTIAL TO DEVELOP NEW
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS LIKE
INSURANCE THEY CAN TRANSFER HEAT
REST. THAT ALSO REQUIRES THE
STATE TO ADOPT A- A NEW. HEAT
WAVE RANKING SYSTEM SO IT IS
IMPORTANT BILL IT WILL PLUG THE
HOLES IN THE STATE'S FLEDGLING
EFFORTS YOUR DRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE- AND IT IMPRESSES THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF HEAT AND WILL
REDUCE PREVENTABLE DEATHS. I
ASKED RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. OTHER OTHER.
WITNESSES- ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
OF THE BILL MISTER CHAIR.
JUSTICE THANK YOU. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AS THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE
AND ALSO WANT TO THANK DOCTOR
WOULD FOR PRESENTING ON THE
BILL. THAT BEING SAID.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I VOTE ON
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ.
OTHER PHONE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PHONE IN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THE STRUCTURE WE SHOW
TWO WITNESSES ON BOTH OF SPOKANE
. THANK YOU ABOUT PUBLIC PHONE
INS. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
VOICE YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE IN Q. ALREADY ON THE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO TO. HI THIS IS
SANTIAGO WITH CALIFORNIAN BY
MENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLS. THANK YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING OUT TO LINE THE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO. GOOD MORNING DAVID AT THE
VIDEO FOR A RP CALIFORNIA AS HE
GETS THE NUMBER ONE WEATHER
RELATED CONTENT DEATH AMONG
OLDER AMERICANS- ARE. AMONG THE
AMERICANS OUT THERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AMOUNT OF
THAT NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO. HAD
MOST AFFECTED BY HEAT WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COST OF COMMENTERS IN. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO THE OPPOSE.
PHYSICIANS IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WISHES
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. THERE
APPEARS TO BE NO ONE WILL GO TO
MISTER OPERATOR FOR ANY OPPOSE
WITNESSES OR GENERAL PUBLIC.
PHONE INS GO AHEAD SIR. SHOWING
NO WITNESSES WHO HAVE NOT YET
SPOKEN WITH ONE OF THE PUBLIC
NOW AGAIN TO- VOICE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF NO PUBLIC
RESPONDENTS QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES THE TESTIMONY- I THINK
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON
THE BILL- MS RIVAS. YOUR STAFF
CAN FILL YOU IN ON HOW MR WOULD
ALMOST. RAN YOUR BILL OFF THE
RAILS. IT WAS A VERY KIND AND
GENEROUS OFFER THAT HE MADE. BUT
IT IT ALMOST IT ALMOST BACKFIRED
BUT TO WE ALL RESCUED. THE
SITUATION AND WE'RE GLAD THAT
YOU SHOWED UP. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
APPRECIATE DR WOULD- FILLING IN
FOR ME WHILE I TRANSITIONED UP
HERE FROM THE BUDGETS OF THREE
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR HEARING
THIS BILL AND YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS OPPOSITION TO LEAD
THE NATION IN THE STOP WISHING
THE FIRST EVER RANKING SYSTEM
FOR HEAT WAVES. AND SO TODAY I
ASK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS AND REALLY- IS SINCERELY
WE DO APPRECIATE MISTER WOODS
SO- OFFER- AND IT WORKED OUT
PRETTY WELL. OF THE BILL ENJOYS
A- A POSITIVE RECOMMENDATION
THIS IS ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND VOTE THEM. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY OUR DAILY I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES FRONT AS AYE CHAN CHAN
I COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE GIPSON GIPSON I
GRAYSON. RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL VOEPEL
NOT VOTING WOULD WHAT I. THAT
HAS TEN YES VOTES OF THE BILL
HAS PASSED THIS COMMITTEE WILL
LEAVE THE HEARING OPEN SO YOU
MAY GET A FEW MORE VOTES SO WHEN
MR GRAYSON RETURNS AND I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHERS THANK
YOU ALL TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS. WE'LL
KEEP THE HEARING OPEN FOR A
WHILE SO THAT- ADD ONS. YEAH GO
AHEAD. CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN
BERMAN I GIPSON GIPSON I. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR BERMAN BERMAN I
GIPSON I. I. THIRTEEN ZERO. THAT
ENDED UP WITH THIRTEEN YES VOTES
. WHICH ONE WAS THAT DEAFENING
SORRY FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR GOOD THANK
YOU. THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
BERMAN YES HI BERMAN I GIPSON
GIPSON I. BUT THAT WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE. THAT WOULD HAVE ELEVEN.
THE DALLAS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE
DAILIES BERMAN. BERMAN I GIPSON
GIPSON I. FILE ITEMNUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
GRAYSON. FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
MR AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
MR BERMAN VOTE ON THAT LAST
GIPSON HI GIPSON I. BERMAN
BERMAN I. THIS ONE JUST STARTED
GOTCHA THANK YOU FOR CONFIRMING
WAY AFTER I'VE NEVER PHYSICALLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE DAILY YEAH.
BUT THANK YOU IT'S OKAY THE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTRA TO THE
SHOW RIGHT THE ONLY ONE I'M
WAITING ON. THANKS CAN. WELL
DONE MR COOLEY. I DON'T HAVE
GRAYSON ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
YEAH WE'RE WAITING FOR MR
GRAYSON- I DON'T MIND WAIT WHAT
BOB HOLDEN HEARING OPEN FOR A
LITTLE WHILE HERE. YEAH HE CAN
ANSWER. ANYTHING. TWENTY THREE.
CONSENT CALENDAR SPARKING ZERO.
SO WE'RE WE'RE TELLING THE VOTES
HERE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PASSED- THIRTEEN TO ZERO. FOR AT
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR THIRTEEN
ZERO. MR COOLEY'S TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FOUR. PAST THIRTEEN TO
ZERO. NUMBER FIVE. ZERO MR
COOLEY'S. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT PASSED ELEVEN TO ZERO.
NUMBER SEVEN IS TEN. ONE TONIGHT
LAST MY BILL AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE PAST TEN TO ONE. WHO WAS THE
ONE. MISTER BIGELOW GOOD. CALLS. YOU WE WON'T DO A FINAL TALLY
ON MISS REAVIS IS BILL TWENTY TO
THIRTY EIGHT UNTIL MR GRAYSON
RETURNS. SAME FOR SANTIAGO'S
BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT WE
WON'T DO A FINAL TALLY UNTIL. WE
GET MR GRAYSON A CHANCE TO
RECORD HIS VOTE.
THEY SAID HE JUST HAD OVER OVER
CREATION. HAVING TO TAKE A LOOK
HERE THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FOR MR GRAYSON AND FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I TH I
HAVE A FEELING THAT HE'S GONNA
THAT'S GONNA TAKE A WHILE. CHECK
WITH THEM I'LL GIVE THEM A
COUPLE MINUTES THANK YOU SIR
WE'LL GIVE THEM A COUPLE MINUTES
TO LET US KNOW BUT I HAVE A
FEELING. HE WON'T BE RETURNING
HERE.
I THINK THE DIE IS CAST HERO
THAT HE WILL NOT BE RETURNING I
HAVE THAT GUT SENSE BECAUSE HE'S
WORKING ON A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
OVER THERE. ADD TO THAT IS IT
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS YEAH. SO
FAR EVERYONE WHO'S HAS VOTED WHO
. I WANTED TO VOTE NUMBER TEN IS
TEN ZERO. THE THREE OF US BILL
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT PAST
TEN TO ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN IS. ELEVEN ZERO MISTER
SANTIAGO'S BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT PASSED ELEVEN TO
ZERO. AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
TALLIES. FOR ALL THE BILLS FOR
ALL TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S.
FILE AND IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS TO BE CONDUCTED HERE AS
PART OF THIS HEARING THE HEARING
IS. ADJOURNED.